[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi chiamo nicola conversa sono un
regista uno sceneggiatore probabilmente
sono di più grande bluff che vedrete
questa sera anche perché parlare dopo
l'opera tour morita really musicista
incredibile un po complicato per
raccontare il mio viaggio la mia
esperienza ho bisogno un attimo di
parlarvi di malattia e sindrome che pare
una cosa brutta e mi incarto ma in
realtà non è così ha provato a cercare
su google
quante malattie esistono al mondo e il
risultato è infinito perché conosciamo
virus e batteri si evolvono a velocità
gigantesca allora ho scovato una sezione
di malattie strane che mi ha fatto dire
a queste persone
realmente vivono con questo problemi con
questi problemi a volte ho anke noi a
volte ci lamentiamo del traffico o di
chi magari per strada ha fatto finta di
non vederci per salutarci magari era
miope e non ci ha messo sul serio io
stesso mi arrabbio tantissimo quando
magari mi mandano un messaggio e alla
fine non c'è la faccina e l'emoticon e
dicono perché ho fatto magari tre
settimane fa gli ho risposto male nel 94
magari offeso l'hanno menata lui non usa
l'emoticon questo per dirvi che esistono
delle malattie come per esempio la
sindrome di mobius la signora immobili
mobius e ti blocca le espressioni
facciali
non puoi mai più sorridere essere triste
per tutta la vita immaginate una persona
seria sto divertendo veramente
tantissimo
poi c'è la trinité la
tripla trim la sindrome del motore di
pesce morto ovvero alcune persone
secernono e le ascelle l'odore di pesce
marcio probabilmente ne avete incontrate
durante le scuole superiori persone che
non sapevano di avere questa sindrome
c'è la sindrome della mano aliena ovvero
tu non controlli la mano e questa si
muove da solo e poi rifilare addirittura
a colpirti e poi c'è la signora di cui
soffre la sindrome dell'impostore magari
qualcuno di voi più ansioso ne soffre e
non lo sa non è nulla di grave chi ne
soffre non si sente all'altezza delle
situazioni che sta vivendo o che vivrà
fino a sentirsi un impostore alcune
persone per esempio sono convinte che
l'essere entrato in un'area facoltoso
universita baudo aver avuto un bel
lavoro sia frutto del culo o di una
sovrastima delle proprie capacità quindi
io in realtà che faccio prova a
spiegarvelo come ho fatto con mia nonna
io sono un content of writing
nella stessa piazza e miano
faccio lo screenwriter
faccio il
screenwriter junior senior niente faccio
lo sceneggiatore che non ho detto a
tutti trovino
io faccio banalmente video per vivere
faccio video e ho iniziato undici anni
fa in una cameretta con degli amici
perché volevamo raccontare delle storie
quando gli internet undici anni fa non
si usava solamente per diventare
popolari nel breve lasso di tempo a
questa smania incredibile di essere
famosi noi volevamo farlo perché
volevamo raccontare delle storie e
soprattutto perché youtube era gratis e
quindi era l'unico modo per avere un
pubblico gratis noi vogliamo raccontare
i nostri piccoli video virali ha
iniziato ad avere visualizzazioni prima
centinaia migliaia fino arrivare a
milioni che non ricordo esattamente
quanti sono ne so scrivere è il pubblico
che era prima la vicina di casa la mamma
è parente arrivato fino a un milione e
mezzo di iscritti ed è tutto molto bello
anche perché i brand si sono avvicinati
a noi e hanno deciso di pagarci per
parlare di un prodotto creare una storia
attorno un prodotto quindi è diventato
un vero e proprio lavoro lavoro sì che
per continuato per continuare a fare
sono dovuto andar via assieme agli altri
perché se mia nonna non capiva cosa
stava succedendo della mia vita anche i
miei amici le persone attorno a me non
capivano benissimo che cosa stessi
facendo faccio il regista e per vivere
faccio il regista e quindi se non ci
credono agli altri a volte tende a non
crederci neanche tu e sono dovuto andare
via a volte ci hanno chiamati vigliacchi
ma non è molto viva come via non rimane
sul territorio però la gente
non lo sa il voto che ti lascia partire
non lo so non lo sa il voto che ti
lascia lasciare casa lasciare la
famiglia lasciare il mare perché il mare
è una toppa è una roba seria
cosa ne sanno quando il cuscino non ha
più la stessa forma il materasso nella
più la stessa forma cosa ne sanno che
non sentirai più una voce che dice
pronto a che ora torni che primo diavola
ti manca che ne sanno di quando ti
affacci di appoggi sul cuscino e pensi
quella del soffitto
ma chi me l'ha fatto fare ce la farò e
lui sa cosa che puoi fare è stare zitto
ingoiare e camminare e camminare perché
quando mi è stata data la possibilità di
scrive un cortometraggio mezzanotte 00
io l'ho voluto girare a taranto per
spiegare che i rantoli per imparare per
tornare qui a far vedere di che saranno
capaci e l'ho fatto mi essendo un
piccolissimo minuscolo a budget
l'abbiamo girato perché volevo dire
azione stop a casa mia il problema è che
ho voluto fare il passo più lungo della
gamba l'ho voluto iscrivere ai david
donatello agli oscar italiani e lì ho
scoperto che venire dal web serrati sul
web è un autogol clamoroso a come fare
il regista bello dove studiato assegnato
didatta sul web dove andare tu scrivi si
fi sul web dove andare al avete girato
tutto senza professionisti si è supposto
dove deve andare allora io li ho fatto
una vigliaccata ho prenotato da quattro
anni fa dagli una settimana il 15
febbraio un aereo per ritornare a
taranto lasciando tutti senza diventa
nessuno perché forse avevano ragione gli
altri forse era un gioco è lì che ho
conosciuto la sindrome dell'impostore
che mi ha bussato e mi ha detto guarda
che tu non sia all'altezza sulle
probabili a te tu non hai nulla da
raccontare
inutile che di spazi per uno che vuole
raccontare e allora ho deciso di tornare
ma la vita si sa a volte e piglia una
piega e tu non puoi farci niente perché
il 14 febbraio il giorno prima della mia
partenza mattarella su raiuno annuncia
che il nostro cortometraggio il mio
cortometraggio la mia storia era
diventato a fini la finalista nella era
cinquina finalista nei david di
donatello per sempre e da lì non si
sarebbe mai più mossa sarebbe stata lì e
il giorno dopo mi ha chiamato una disney
e mi ha fatto girare una serie
internazionale perché se n'è fregata che
veniva dal web se ne fregava
assolutamente perché le interessava io
voglio soltanto raccontare dall'inps
sono arrivate serie tv un libro pieno di
storie
ne è stata data la possibilità di
raccontare nel momento in cui io avevo
smesso di crederci per colpa della
sindrome dell'impostore perché vedete
per noi ansiosi camminare in un
territorio inesplorato nel deserto le
nuove esperienze lo puoi fare soltanto
con la frase per antonomasia sbagliando
si impara il problema che nel 2000 21 se
sbagli non è detto che ti venga dato un
altro porto quindi per noi ansiosi e
l'unica benzina per andare dritti e
ricevere una pacca sulla spalla da
chiamiamo dei nostri genitori della
nostra ragazza al nostro fidanzato o un
bravo quella è la benzina che fa andare
avanti e per chi non è capace di
ricevere delle pacche sulle spalle
fidatevi
nasce un processo di assenza perché c'è
la distanza genera assenza e la distanza
se ci pensate bene è risolvibile in
maniera matematica ma l'assenza no ma
senza la risolvete con l'equazione è
l'assenza genera vuoto e il vuoto genera
silenzio è il silenzio se si è ansioso a
un rumore che sembra una discoteca e
allora vuol dire che se è guarito quindi
dalla sindrome dell'impostore no ho
scoperto che non ci si può guarire è
diventata una mia compagna di viaggio
avete presente quel compagno che ci
avete accanto durante un lungo viaggio
che ogni tanto dorme si sveglia
accenderà musica parla parla parla ogni
tanto dorme e non mi calcolano intanto
arriva e fa non vai bene non va
assolutamente bene fai schifo hanno
scelto un altro perché si è molto più
bravo di te allora li di vista da
pensare che fondamentalmente chi soffre
della sindrome dell'impostore sono
quelle persone che nella vita sono
arrivate quasi prime perché se ci
pensate bene arrivare quasi primo è
terribile perché si ricordano tutti il
numero uno ma il numero 2 sanremo e
maneschi nel secondo
sul lato sport quest'anno magari delle
risposte dell'inghilterra ma se ci
pensate bene gli inglesi non hanno vinto
per un centesimo di secondo
un centesimo poi al supermercato un
centesimo di serie un centesimo ma si
sbuffate quando ve lo danno allora
immaginate l'inglese che è arrivato
quasi secondo per un centesimo di
secondo cosa può aver fatto aver pensato
quattro anni di sacrifici di notti
insonne per arrivare quasi secondo e
quando arrivi sempre secondo come è
successo a me inizia a credere nel
momento in cui arrivi primo non te lo
meriti perché stato culo perché sia
arrivato lì e allora inizia a capire che
tutti no che prenderai nella vita sono
superiori si allora devi imparare che
quei pochi si tu cacchio li devi
difendere perché non quest'ora pensare a
tutti noi che hai preso tu devi
difenderti questi e soprattutto ho
imparato soltanto che quando vedrete un
muro un ostacolo un no beh non può anche
non abbatterci perché i muri degli
ostacoli si è imparato a guardare li
possono essere degli enormi e altissimi
trampolini per saltare ancora più in
alto quella all'altro guardato in basso
sperate di arrivare quasi primi
[Applauso]